elon musk the world's richest man and
the founder of spacex tesla boring
company neurolink and many others was
recently on the nok boyz podcast and
they asked him about the prospects of a
potential recession here's what elon had
to say yeah do you think we're headed
into like a big recession i don't think
we're headed into a big recession i'd
say like maybe a mild recession
um but it could be
a mild recession that lasts for a couple
years something like that you know but
the the thing that's hard to predict is
like you know like if there's like a war
between china and taiwan or something
like that that would send the world into
a recession you know that's always part
that's a possibility you know if it's
not like big big event you know
and and there there is a challenge in
china right now with um
the taiwan china taiwan china stuff is
this worrying time
there is an independent of that there is
um
there's kind of
a looming um bust in the uh property
market in in china where there's just
been they've over built
apartments and buildings in general
there's just too many
20 housing too many primary housing
units in china which seems crazy because
a lot of people in china but that
that'll be that's a correction that's
gonna happen it's fascinating to hear
someone like elon musk who has so much
data at his fingertips talk about a
recession in this way but this isn't the
only comments that elon has made
publicly in recent days about a
potential mild recession here's elon
talking at the tesla annual shareholder
meeting just a few days ago about a
potential recession my guess is that
we're past peak inflation
and
that we will see
we will have a recession i think it will
be a relatively mild recession
sort of uh
but i'm just guessing here this is total
uh
speculation
um but i would guess it's a it's a
you know mild recession for
i don't know 18 months or something like
that it would be my best guess right now
we don't have fundamental capital
misallocations in the
in the us
as we have had in the past like in
leading up to 2008 where we were
building primary housing units at twice
the rate of of household formation which
obviously doesn't make sense
um and there were
a lot of companies were
over levered the the leverage or debt
that companies have right now is
relatively low
so
yeah i would say probably
you know mild moderate recession maybe
18 months
ish
and i think we i think inflation is
going to drop
rapidly that's my guess now most
executives and ceos will be the first to
say they aren't macro investors they
don't really predict the future and
they're often wrong but it's important
to pay attention to what they're saying
because they have immense amounts of
data they have entire teams dedicated to
understanding their supply chains the
cost of commodities the labor market and
what their customers want including
sentiment and actual purchasing demand
ultimately the ceos are a great signal
for how businesses are thinking about
potential recessions and where they see
strengths in an economy hearing elon
musk talk about a mild recession for
about 18 months or so he's unlikely to
be exactly correct but directionally i
think that we should heed this warning
and people should start preparing for
worse times at the end of the day elon
musk runs a number of companies that
have to touch multiple supply chains
many different geographic regions and
across industries that means that he's
better suited than most to talk about
what he's seeing on the ground and where
he thinks the world is going be prepared
my friends for the worst and we'll
continue to hope for the best elon musk
thinks we're headed towards an 18-month
recession what do you think let me know
in the comments hey you did you like
this video great make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time